rachel zegler may go to the oscars after
all the young actress who plays maria in
the remake of west side story had said
she was not invited to sunday's academy
awards well fans on social media were
outraged we were kind of out
but she's got millions of fans on social
media uh and she's not nominated but the
movie did pick up seven nods including
best picture now the hollywood reporter
says the academy of motion picture arts
and sciences has invited her to be a
presenter good we reached out to the
academy and zegler's reps we haven't
heard back because she isn't a nominee
it was up to 28th century studios and
the parent company which is disney to
offer zegler a seat at the oscars so
disney got hammered disney got hammered
and a spokesperson told entertainment
weekly that zegler wasn't invited due to
a scheduling issue because she's filming
snow white in london
they have these things called planes
where people go people awards and you
get on a plane
i feel like we played a role in that too
i feel like we probably did i'm so glad
it worked out though will packers is
producing the show this year i think
this is a great addition and she's going
to be a presentation which is awesome
yeah so instead of being in sweats and
in her boyfriend's flannel on the couch
she can now walk the red carpet exactly
i just love her story yeah chosen out of
thirty thousand to play maria we love it
no doubt about it
all right